good morning John top ten week has
turned out to be quite fun I hope we do
it again sometime
can you imagine breaking your arm and
then stabbing someone with the bone but
really I think the exploring ant
deserved his place at the top of that
list but that got me thinking about the
biggest and most awe-inspiring
explosions of all time number one the
very first large man-made explosion
happened in 1654 in the Dutch town of
Delft when a 30 tons store of gunpowder
exploded it pretty much destroyed the
entire town and kind of created the idea
of a bomb but really on the scale of
things not a very big explosion the
second explosion I'm gonna talk about is
the largest accidental explosion of all
time it happened outside of the Canadian
port of Halifax when two boats crashed
into each other unfortunately one of the
boats was carrying nothing but
explosives for use in World War one it
created a tsunami and killed over 2,000
people and pretty much destroyed the
entire town of Halifax Nova Scotia
number three the world's second largest
explosion before the advent of nuclear
weapons was the intentional destruction
of an island in the East River so that
they could open up the East River to
shipping unfortunately that one was too
long ago to have video footage of it
however there was a similar Island
destruction in British Columbia in the
1950s and we do have video of that yeah
explosion number four the largest
explosion before the advent of nuclear
weapons kill around 10,000 Germans
during World War one so the British
troops actually dug under the German
lines and laid down a huge amount of
explosives the evening before the attack
the British general was quoted as saying
gentlemen tomorrow we may not change
history but we certainly will change
geography and before we get to nuclear
weapons cuz we're gonna get there let's
talk about the largest non-nuclear
weapon ever designed by the US the
massive ordnance air blast bomb or Moab
is also sometimes called the mother of
all bombs it has roughly the explosive
power of 12 tons of TNT and can destroy
a 10 city block radius and now's when we
start making really big jumps so we go
from the Moab which was a big bang to a
much bigger bang which is a very small
nuclear weapon fat man and little boy
were the only nuclear weapons actually
used in warfare dropped on Hiroshima and
Nagasaki
roughly a thousand times bigger than the
Moab explosion number seven the Ivy King
was the largest fission bomb of all time
roughly thirty times the size of the
bomb dropped on Hiroshima there's
something in my eye
explosion number eight the Tunguska
event happened in 1908 and no one is
quite sure what happened but whatever it
was had an explosive force larger than
1,000 Hiroshima bombs the most prominent
theory that it was very small comment
that because of atmospheric pressure and
the heat of reentry had actually
exploded before it hit the ground
explosion number nine the Tsar bomb was
actually probably like five times bigger
than the Tunguska event which Wow the
Tsar bomb with a 15 Megaton equivalents
is roughly the size of four thousand
Hiroshima bombs explosion number ten the
largest explosion and fairly recent
geological history of the earth was the
volcanic eruption that left behind
Yellowstone National Park for those of
you who don't know Yellowstone National
Park one of America's most prized
natural wonders which is a mere hundred
miles away from where I'm sitting right
now is actually a volcanic caldera the
last time it erupted was six hundred and
forty thousand years ago and the force
of that explosion was roughly seventeen
thousand times that not of the Hiroshima
bomb but of the 50-megaton Tsar bomb the
scary part is geologists say Yellowstone
is due for another eruption ok I I live
way too close to this thing so I hope I
freaked you out can you imagine living
in a time where there was actually a
feasibility of global nuclear war I
don't even live in the 50s and I want to
go villa bomb shelter if you missed the
other two top ten videos you can see
them right now I'm gonna put an
annotation link up John I will see you
on Monday